JESSE HOLMES (VOICEOVER):
Nothing's going to stop me.
Snow, wind, 40 below--
things like that don't stop me.
[music playing]
Couldn't be any better
time to finish this up.
The dogs are all resting well.
Now it's time to keep after it.
I don't want to leave
this undone and wait.
Because this is just going
to accumulate. , Here, Rosie.
You play with your pig, and
I'll take care of the window.
OK?
NARRATOR: Jesse
Holmes has nearly
completed the new addition
to his home in Brushkana.
But with winter
already descending
on the landscape and his new
bedroom still incomplete,
Jesse will need to work
through the bitter cold night
if he's to be shielded
from the coming storm.
JESSE HOLMES: All
right, one more
step to make this a room here.
Get this window out, and looks
like I can wiggle it out right
here and keep it from breaking.
There's a big sense
of vulnerability
moving this window.
I've been able to do a
lot in the last couple
of weeks since my surgery.
But I'm still really weak.
And having to move this window
is the crux of this whole deal.
There it goes.
Nice and easy.
OK.
Now it's time for the big lift.
I've been struggling for five
weeks to get strong again.
And I'm still 80%.
And this window is 100% job.
You get one chance.
You drop it, it
breaks, I don't have
another window to put in here.
Oh, man.
I am having a hard time here.
[sighs]
Just ain't as strong as I was.
There it goes.
[banging]
[drilling]
All right.
That's the final screw
locking it down, here.
Take a look at it
and let it soak in.
I'm exhausted from
a long day of work.
But I'm glad that I
committed, cut the window out,
got it in there.
That's a big step.
Now everything is just
making things aesthetic.
Rosie, come.
Get your limelight.
Come, come.
Hey, come and check it out.
Look, we got a new bedroom.
Yeah, look at all that new
room for you to terrorize in.
Huh?
Yeah.
Do you like it?
To me, having this home here
is a symbol of never giving up.
Through these last
couple of years,
I've been to the breaking
point to where I didn't
think I could take it anymore.
And then I keep going and
block it out of my mind,
keep focused.
Eventually, you just become
as hard as the surroundings.
It doesn't kill you.
And then it tempers you
and makes you stronger.
I didn't just move out
here to train dogs.
I moved out here to
become a better man.
And every day this landscape
molds you into that.
Anywhere around here, I feel
a sense of satisfaction.
This is a place with a
lot of future for me.
It's hard not to get emotional.
This is something that I have
wanted for myself for so long.
And I don't even know
what to do with it.
And I'm just going to let
it play out from here.
But I see really good things
happening in the future.
[music playing]